Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhassa
Homage au Bouddha, le noble, l'éveillé, celui qui a réalisé l'immigration par lui-même.
Je voudrais maintenant aller dans les points principaux de notre pratique et aussi d'exposer les empêchements.
Pourquoi est-il tellement important d'assister, d'être dans le moment présent ?
Qu'importe quelles sont les méthodes de pratique telles que le Zen, le Theravada, l'important c'est d'être dans le moment présent.
Alors vous pouvez comparer votre réponse avec moi.
Quand nous parlons du moment présent,
Ça signifie que, disons, nous le voyons tel quel et que nous... et ce n'est pas que nous voyons ce qu'il devrait être.
Qu'est-ce qui nous arrête de voir le moment présent tel qu'il est ?
Dites-le vous-même, ce n'est pas un test.
Chaque fois que nous sommes dans le moment présent nous amenons le passé avec nous dans le moment présent.
Réfléchissez.
Quand vous allez dans un restaurant et que vous commandez une pizza avant de manger la pizza, vous savez très bien comment la pizza sera.
Vous avez eu des centaines de pizzas.
Vous avez des centaines de pizzas, beaucoup de pizzas.
Et vous avez vu des programmes de télévision, comment faire une pizza.
Vous avez déjà discuté sur la pizza avec vos amis.
Quand vous commandez une pizza, vous savez que c'est une pizza idéale.
Quand vous savez que la pizza ne correspond pas à votre idéal de pizza ce n'est pas une pizza.
Chaque fois que vous avez une expérience, nous la définissons par rapport à l'expérience passée, à ce que nous avons expérimenté dans le passé.
Supposons quelqu'un vous invite chez lui ou chez elle pour avoir une pizza.
Je ne sais pas comment on vend les pizzas ici.
Mais, disons, il y a des pizzas qui sont servies à, disons, qui ont été réfrigérées, qui ont été congelées, oui.
Vous pouvez les mettre dans la micro-onde.
Si votre ami vous invite à que vous servez ce genre de pizza,
Alors, vous pensez que ce n'est vraiment pas une pizza.
Mais vous la mangez quand même, disons, par respect pour votre ami.
Pour ne pas insulter votre ami.
Nous supposons que vous n'avez jamais eu une pizza dans votre vie.
et que vous mangez celle-là comme votre première pizza, alors vous pourrez dire à votre ami que vous avez eu un repas formidable,
Une tranche de pizza un peu douteuse avec une petite tomate, oui.
Alors, vous pouvez voir, chaque moment que nous passons, chaque moment que nous expérimentons, nous apportons tout notre passé à ce moment-là.
Même quand vous êtes entré dans cette chambre,
Vous devriez avoir eu une opinion qui s'est élevée Oui, une opinion Une opinion préconçue Bonne, pas bonne, agréable, désagréable Donc le esprit est toujours en jugement
et toujours en train de juger par rapport à l'expérience passée.
Et l'esprit n'expérience jamais le moment présent dans toute sa fraîcheur.
De cette façon, nous continuons notre délusion sur la vie.
Par ce processus, nous continuons notre illusion, notre illusion sur ce qu'est la vie.
Chaque matin, nous nous réveillons et nous disons, voilà, je suis là.
Le soir, quand on se couche, on dit au revoir.
Nous disparaissons.
Où sommes-nous quand nous dormons ?
Qui êtes-vous quand vous dormez ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez être une célébrité quand vous dormez ?
Et quand le réveil sonne, voilà, vous êtes là.
Vous réappariez.
Est-ce que vous êtes la même personne qui a été laissée coucher la veille ?
Il semble que ce soit le cas.
Nous ne nous sentons pas différents, disons, de ce que nous étions quand nous nous allons nous coucher.
Alors, essentiellement, quand je me réveille, je me dis, tiens, voilà, je suis de nouveau là.
Alors, ce « moi », ça se rapporte à quoi ?
Le corps.
Est-ce que c'est le même corps que j'avais quand j'avais deux ans ?
Est-ce que c'est les mêmes émotions que j'avais quand j'avais deux, trois ans ?
Est-ce que ce sont les mêmes pensées que j'avais quand j'avais deux ou trois ans ?
Quand j'avais dix ans, vingt ans, quarante ans ?
Alors qu'est-ce que ça signifie « moi » ?
Alors, notre pratique, notre méditation, c'est de nous amener dans le moment présent sans aucune histoire de passé.
Et qu'est-ce que ça signifie, notre histoire, notre passé ?
Des pensées.
Ce sont les pensées.
Les concepts.
Nos concepts et nos pensées amènent, disons, nos expériences passées.
À chaque fois que je dis « pizza »,
j'imagine une centaine de sortes de pizzas à chaque fois que je dis moi qu'est-ce que, disons, j'amène, qu'est-ce que je pense ?
toute mon éducation
tout, disons, le concept que j'ai de moi-même, tous les jugements que j'ai, disons, sur moi.
À chaque fois, je transporte ce fardeau
et je m'accroche à ce fardeau.
Tout ce fardeau, tout ce bagage-là, disons, revient à un seul mot.
Moi.
Dans la méditation, nous essayons de nous débarrasser de toute cette histoire de tout ce moi.
Comment le faisons-nous ?
Nous le faisons principalement en
C'est pourquoi dans cette tradition qui est enseignée par le Vénérable Mahasi nous n'utilisons qu'un seul mot pour chaque chose que nous faisons.
Quand nous contemplons la respiration, c'est seulement lever, descendre, ou bien pour la marche, soulever et abaisser.
En utilisant un seul mot,
naturellement nous ne pensons pas à autre chose mais mon attention mon attention n'est pas sur le mot ce n'est pas sur la pensée c'est sur la sensation donc il y a une intelligence dans nous
Il y a une intelligence en nous qui ne pense pas.
Dans notre société, dans notre dictation, nous pensons
de l'intelligence c'est la pensée c'est pensée nous pensons que disons l'intelligence c'est l'imagerie disons la philosophie les arts et ça c'est l'intelligence
Alors, les arts, la philosophie, la technologie, disons, tout ça, c'est seulement l'expression de l'intelligence, mais ce n'est pas l'intelligence.
Just as a picture, a beautiful picture is an expression of an emotional experience, but it is not the emotional experience.
C'est comme une peinture, bien sûr, une image, disons, belle, qui est seulement l'expression, disons, l'expression émotionnelle, mais ce n'est pas l'émotion elle-même.
Nous devrons redécouvrir notre intelligence originale.
La période où nous avons cette intelligence originelle, c'est quand nous étions petits.
Quand vous voyez que, disons, les enfants qui comptent quelque chose, vous pouvez voir que leurs yeux sont fixés, disons, à l'objet qu'ils regardent.
Absolute stillness.
When the jaw is relaxed in meditation and the tongue is relaxed, it means that you can't think.
Quand la mâchoire est étendue et que la langue est tendue, ça signifie que vous ne pouvez pas penser.
Vous pouvez expérimenter ça quand vous marchez dans un parc.
Quand vous détendez votre mâchoire et votre langue, vous pensez à diminuer.
Quand un enfant regarde quelque chose avec toute la réceptivité, il n'y a aucune pensée dans son esprit.
Ils ne viennent pas d'une position, d'une opinion.
parce que l'enfant n'a pas, disons, d'opinion.
Quand ils s'arrêtent pour regarder et demandent ce que c'est, les parents disent que c'est une... comment ça s'appelle ?
Un aton, un aton.
Coccinelle.
Alors, maintenant, ils ont vu le coccinelle, ils vont pouvoir découvrir une autre coccinelle.
Alors, chaque fois qu'ils voient une nouvelle coccinelle, l'enfant ne va pas
cette coccinelle là mais va prendre disons va amener la coccinelle du passé quand nous voulons redécouvrir la nouvelle coccinelle on devrait
contempler, la contempler, la contempler, puisqu'au moment où il n'y a plus de pensée.
Et c'est à ce moment-là que nous pourrons redécouvrir la coccinelle.
C'est comme si vous sentez un parfum comme celui de la rose.
Vous devez continuer à la sentir jusqu'au moment où le concept rose disparaît.
C'est seulement quand le mot
Donc, vous pouvez comprendre, si nous voulons voir nous-mêmes comme nous le sommes, nous devons aller au-delà de n'importe quel concept de qui nous sommes.
si vous découvrez ce que vous êtes vraiment vous devrez aller au-delà de tous les concepts du moi la force de la méditation c'est de nous amener dans le moment présent sans aucun cancer donc la première chose que nous pouvons arrêter c'est de arrêter de penser à quelque chose
La première chose que nous devons faire, c'est d'arrêter de penser à quelque chose.
Si nous utilisons, disons, un seul mot comme « penser »,
rêver, douleur, plaisir, tristesse, à ce moment-là nous arrêtons, disons, vraiment de penser.
À ce moment-là, nous arrêtons de penser à quelque chose.
Et en utilisant une simple parole pour garder l'esprit pensant à l'aise, nous pouvons mettre notre attention sur les sensations et les sentiments.
À ce moment-là, disons, si nous pourrons, disons, garder l'esprit sur un mot et garder l'esprit immobile, à ce moment-là nous pourrons ressentir les sensations.
Les sentiments sont immédiats.
Vous ne pouvez plus avoir une sensation d'hier.
Vous ne pouvez plus ressentir les sensations d'hier.
Vous ne pouvez plus ressentir même les émotions des derniers moments.
Donc, si nous pouvons ressentir une sensation maintenant, si nous pouvons ressentir un état émotionnel maintenant, nous savons que nous sommes au moment présent.
Si nous pouvons ressentir une sensation maintenant et une émotion maintenant, c'est que nous sommes dans le moment présent.
Chaque fois que l'esprit, disons, va vagabond et disons rêve ou bien fantasme, à ce moment-là, nous sommes complètement en dehors du moment présent.
Quand l'esprit veut vagabonder, on ne peut pas l'empêcher.
Quand nous voulons arrêter l'esprit, disons, ou bien, disons,
Donc, vous devez traiter l'esprit comme vous le feriez un petit chien.
Vous le traitez comme un petit chien.
quand nous l'entrainons à s'asseoir et quand il nous demande de revenir, revenir nous devons être, disons, gentils
mais ferme avec l'esprit.
Et quand nous sommes assis et que l'esprit vagabonde, disons, nous devons noter, disons comme, par exemple, rêver, rêver, après le ramener vers la respiration.
Quand nous nous éveillons et que nous nous sentons anxieux nous ne revenons pas, disons, vers la respiration ou bien vers le corps mais nous devons
disons, noter la sensation, disons, anxieux, soucis, soucis.
L'émotion ou bien le fantasme, disons, va nous indiquer quelle est la sensation qui nous perturbe.
Disons, nous sommes excités et que nous sentons en colère, nous devons les noter, mais nous devons revenir vers la sensation.
Nous devons comprendre très clairement que l'émotion
ne peut pas se développer, disons, sans que ce soit une conséquence de l'esprit et de l'imagination
disons, ils utilisent les pensées et l'image pour se développer l'imagination.
C'est...
Si nous expérimentons une émotion comme une sensation dans le corps, nous essayons de le recevoir et nous le laissons disparaître.
L'émotion va, disons, la suger d'elle-même.
Il faudrait vous souvenir que ce sont que des énergies, ce sont des énergies.
Ils ont besoin, disons, de votre implication pour se développer.
Ils viennent automatiquement quand vous commencez à penser.
Donc, par exemple, je suis sûr que
Je suis sûr que, par exemple, quelqu'un vous dit quelque chose qui vous déplaît ce matin, et vous le rejetez comme une stupidité,
Mais quand vous avez un verre de café ou de thé... Et pendant le déjeuner, vous donnez à la personne un coup de poing.
Quand vous arrivez, disons, vers le soir, vous aurez besoin d'un aspirine.
Cette personne ne vous a insulté qu'une seule fois.
Mais vous vous assurez qu'elle, finalement, elle vous insulte un millier de fois.
le cerveau, la pensée, la pensée.
Et donc, ces émotions se développent.
Quand nous comprenons vraiment cela, nous ferons un effort, non seulement en méditation, mais dans toutes nos vies.
Quand nous en comprenons ça, non seulement dans les sessions de méditation, mais dans la vie courante, nous devons arrêter, disons, tous ces fantasmes.
La méditation, c'est seulement pour pratiquer comment vivre la vie de tous les jours.
Donc, ce que l'esprit pense, peu importe ce que c'est, agréable ou non, peu importe, vous le notez et vous revenez à l'esprit, vous revenez à la sensation, à l'émotion, dans le corps, comme un ressenti.
Quand une émotion vient, que ce soit agréable ou désagréable, vous revenez... N'importe quelle pensée, agréable, désagréable, vous revenez sur la sensation dans le corps.
en tant que sensation comme vous l'expérimentez dans votre corps cette intelligence que nous discutons doit être réembodée intégrée
Réintégrer dans le corps.
Ok, donc, c'est notre pratique, marcher, assister, même à l'extérieur, quand vous mangez à lundi, restez avec le corps, avec les sensations de manger, oui ?
Donc, je vais expliquer ça quand nous reprenons le déjeuner.
disons quand nous marchons quand nous disons restons assis ou bien quand nous allons dehors et quand nous mangeons nous devons toujours disons revenir vers la sensation dans le corps le ménage va s'expliquer après donc c'est le côté de la pensée l'autre côté c'est le tombé au sommeil le tombé au sommeil de la lethargie et de la douleur dans la tête
Donc il y a une différence entre être fatigué et être doux et lethargique.
Il y a une différence entre être fatigué et être, disons, léthargique, ou bien, un peu, disons, avoir la torpeur.
La distanciation est un peu difficile, mais quand vous avez bien dormi la nuit précédente, vous pourrez faire la distanciation que quand vous êtes fatigué, ça ne vient pas de la fatigue, mais ça c'est la torpeur.
ou bien la léthargie, quoi.
La torpeur, disons, c'est dans l'esprit, c'est un peu comme un potage.
À ce moment-là, le corps
et disons, disons, ne se sent pas confortable.
Parfois une chose, parfois les deux choses.
Maintenant, où se trouve-t-il
Comment nous développons ces états qui ne sont pas favorables ?
Nous allons constater que c'est, disons que c'est vrai pour tout plaisir.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas vrai que d'aller vous coucher, disons, est plaisant ?
Une des belles choses, disons, pour le sommeil, c'est qu'il n'y a pas de souffrance.
Ce n'est pas le Nibbana, mais il n'y a pas de souffrance.
C'est comme un refuge aussi.
C'est que vous prenez refuge dans le Bouddha, vous prenez refuge dans votre lit.
Quand nous sommes, disons, en colère ou bien déprimés, il y a un signe qui s'allume et qui dit « Allez au lit ».
Allons au lit.
Maintenant, donc, le sommeil est très agréable.
On s'éveille en se sentant, d'habitude, on s'éveille en se sentant frais.
Mais c'est aussi un refuge du danger.
C'est aussi un refuge, disons, contre le danger.
Donc, nous construisons à l'intérieur de nous une condition de tomber au sommeil
quand certaines conditions sont là.
Donc, ici nous sommes, en méditation, en regardant l'esprit, rien ne se passe, c'est très effrayant, nous tombons au sommeil.
Quand nous sommes assis ici, il y a une position de méditation, rien ne se passe, ça devient ennuyeux et nous nous endormons.
Dans notre société maintenant, c'est de créer les excitations.
All the adverts are telling us to do something, buy something, be happier.
If you go to a country where people are still based in an agricultural life,
Vous allez dans un pays où la vie des gens est encore basée sur la préculture quand ils vivent encore, disons
dans le flot facile de la nature.
Rien n'est très excitant qu'on trouve dans la nature.
Normalement dans la nature c'est seulement soit la pluie, soit le soleil,
soit les nuages, soit la pluie de nouveau.
Alors, il n'y a rien, disons, à attendre d'excitant.
Si rien d'excitant, disons, se passe, l'esprit reste éveillé,
L'esprit moderne est toujours poussé à aller vers les excitations, et quand il n'y a pas d'excitation, l'esprit moderne s'endort.
C'est l'une des raisons, je ne sais pas la seule, disons que nous voyons dans le sommeil, disons, le lieu pour trouver le bonheur.
Malheureusement, nous ne pouvons pas, disons, être...
éveillé quand nous dormons c'est pas possible pitié dommage et la raison est que le processus de libération est le processus d'investigation pour voir les choses comme elles sont l'une des raisons pour laquelle le processus de libération
c'est de trouver, disons, c'est dans le processus d'investiguer, d'analyser les choses telles qu'elles sont.
Et cette analyse et cette investigation ne peuvent être faites, disons, qu'en l'absence de pensée.
Nous devons découvrir les choses telles qu'elles sont avant de penser comment elles sont.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie qu'on nous a dit que nous devons voir
Il faut être libéré des souffrances.
Le Bouddha a dit qu'il faudrait qu'on observe trois choses, disons, pour que notre vie soit complètement transformée.
Et je ne demande pas le temps de seulement les mentionner en passant.
La première chose c'est que toutes les choses, disons, apparaissent et disparaissent de manière radicale.
Chaque chose apparaît et disparaît.
La prochaine chose qui apparaît, disons, n'est pas vraiment semblable à la première.
C'est deux choses différentes.
C'est comme les feuilles sur un arbre.
Disons, chaque année, elles ne sont pas les mêmes.
Elles paraissent être les mêmes, mais elles ne sont pas les mêmes.
Elles sont différentes.
C'est comme vous observez votre respiration, la respiration présente est différente de celle qui est passée, qui précède.
La deuxième chose que le Bouddha nous demande de voir, c'est comment on a créé ce qu'on appelle un monde dualiste.
Comment nous aimons quelque chose et comment nous détestons une autre chose.
Ce n'est pas le problème.
Le problème, c'est que quand nous aimons quelque chose, nous le saisissons, nous l'attachons.
Et quand nous n'aimons pas quelque chose, nous essayons de nous en débarrasser.
Et si c'est trop grand, nous l'attaquons.
Si c'est trop dangereux, nous essayons de nous échapper.
Disons les trois choses.
qui expliquent que cet état c'est l'illusion, l'acquisition c'est de la saisie et l'autre c'est la peur.
Yes.
Acquisition.
Acquisition, aversion.
Ça c'est l'acquisition, c'est la saisie, le rejet et l'autre c'est la peur.
La peur.
That's it.
And the third thing that the Buddha says we must see very clearly is
La troisième chose que le Bouddha nous dit d'observer, c'est l'idée qu'on fait de soi, l'idée de soi.
La définition d'un soi, c'est qu'on contrôle, c'est qu'on peut contrôler ce moi.
À ce moment-là, on doit investiguer, disons, ce cycle, disons, ce corps-là,
disons, jusqu'à quelle mesure on peut le contrôler ?
Alors, si on ne peut pas contrôler ce corps-là, disons, ça veut dire que ça ne peut pas être moi.
Disons, ces trois investigations vont saper
disons, notre illusion, disons, d'un soi.
Quand cette illusion va être brisée, le Bouddha ne dit pas que nous allons être inahidés, nous allons disparaître.
Il dit qu'il y a une expérience
disons, nous allons expérimenter, disons, un état qui ne va plus, disons, souffrir ou bien souffrir, ou bien, disons, ressentir la satisfaction
Et cet état, c'est le nibbana.
Nous pouvons nous rapprocher du nibbana dans notre méditation.
En observant, disons, de manière simple,
Simple et pur.
Quand nous pouvons observer le corps avec ses sensations, disons là,
Et quand nous pouvons, disons, observer les sensations là, qui ne sont pas nous...
Et quand vous méditez bien, vous pourrez observer une pensée qui va apparaître et disparaître devant vous.
Vous allez accéder à un poste d'observation.
Et cette position est juste proche du Nibbana.
Juste à côté, proche, proche.
C'est ce que nous essayons, disons, de nous approcher du Nibbana.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'aller nulle part.
Il a dit maintenant qu'il avait donné les bases.
Maintenant vous pouvez faire une méditation marché, il faudrait juste trouver, disons, un espace où vous pourriez faire cinq pas et, disons, aller et revenir, disons, et retourner, quoi.
Disons, un espace où, disons, vous pourriez faire cinq pas.
Vous pouvez trouver une position dans cette salle, dix pas, dix pas.